dede.
D Dr Christian Carrier,
héhématolo-oncologue, chef
dudu service d'hémato-oncologie
dudu CIUSSS de la Mauricie et
dudu Centre-du-Québec, bonsoir.
LeLe cancer c'est ce qui nous ft
lele plus craint quand on parlee
dédélestage, ils donnez-moi l'ét
dedes choses aujourd'hui, est-ce
ququ'il y a des gens qui devrait
êêtrtre revus pour leur santé et
ququi ne le sont pas?
- - Actuellement décédé priorist
popour limiter les dégâtsts nonn
vovoit la plupart des patients
momort-nés en ajustement pour ls
trtraitements, parfois on change
reretard des traitements comme r
exexemple un patient qui a un
momodule pulmonaire qui devrait
êêtrtre hospitalisé mais qui va
plplutôt t avoir une radiothéra,
ilil faut penser que ces jobs de
dédécision va êtrtre pris avec n
cocomité d'experts.
L'L'avaient accompli actuellemet
esest beaucoup plus intense que
cecelle qu'on a vécue dans le
papassé gâchche beaucoup plus de
cocontagion, beaucoup plus de
papatients, plus
d'd'hospitalisation, plus de
pepersonnel atteint ni isolé doc
c'c'est beaucoup plus grave, le
fefeu est pris.
- - comment fait pour êtrtre les
memeilleurs pompiers possibles?
EsEst-ce que vous avez des
sosolutions les oncologues pour
fafaire en sorte qu'on voit plus
dede monde?
- - On utilise la télémédecine,n
trtravaille beaucoup avec les
alalgorithmes qui ont été
développés lors des vagues
prprécédentes, on pense comme
inincapable de donner le service
dadans la mesure qu'on ne manque
papas de personnel, mais c'est r
quque le plus gros problèmeme
acactuellement c'est que l'hôpil
dédéborde des patients si tu
dedevrais êtrtre ailleurs qu'à
l'l'hôpipital et qui n'ont plus
bebesoin des soins de l'hôpipitt
quque ceux qui vienne embuer la
mamachine et pour sa, on va devr
leles relocaliser par d'autres
reressources.
- - Donc il y a des gens des
pepersonnages essentiellement
ququ'on ne peut pas retourner ds
leleur milieu de vie, dans les
CHCHSLD au les RPA, pour ne pas,
dedes mais vous dîtetes qu'il ne
fafaut quand mêmeme les sortir e
leleur talent parce que certains
pepersonnes peuvent pas y entre?
- - Oui comme une personne âgége
ququi tombe et qui doit avoir ue
chchirurgie mineure mais test
popositif à l la COVID ne peut s
reretourner chez lui en CHSLD ou
enen RPA alors à c ce moment, le
papatient va rester à l l'hôpipt
prprendre la place d'une autre
pepersonne qui aurait besoin d'n
sosoin plus aigu.
JeJe pense qu'il faut, incapable
dede relocaliser ses jambes vers
unune d'autres unités, on a
d'd'autres lits qui ne sont pas
ututilisés par manque de
pepersonnel, il faut aussi pensr
àà a amener ces personnes-là  à
l'l'hôtetel avec un encadrementi
n'n'est pas médical, ils ont
bebesoin des personnes autour de
popour veiller sur eux, des aid-
sosoignants par exemple, des ges
ququi ont une très s courte
foformation de quelque chose et
c'c'est là q que le besoin le ps
crcriant actuellement.
SiSi on avait des centaines
d'd'aides-soignants pourrait alr
dadans des hôtetels ou des lieux
cocomme ça et déplacer ces
papatients là-b-bas ces lieux l.
- - Parce qu'il y a des gens qui
viviennent d'apprendre un
didiagnostic de cancer et qui
dedevait avoir une intervention
ququi a été annulée, est-ce qu'l
y y a des gens dans la vie est
memenacée?
- - Immédiatement, non parce que
totous les les urgences sont
fafaites immédiatement et il y a
unun comité d'expert par le trie
éqéquivalent à l la priorisatiol
esest clair qu'il bail avoir des
dédélais dans les prochaines
sesemaines, mais on devrait être
cacapable de tes les réversibles
popour tous ces patients gâchchl
esest clair que les patients qui
n'n'ont pas de de dépistages qui
onont des symptômemes m'ont caué
unune petite vague qui vont durr
dedes années au Québec avec des
gegens confèrere né avec des
mamaladies plus avancées qui
popourraient êtrtre curables mas
ququi ne sont plus curables à
cacause du délai.
- - Les Chiefs Raymonde Killian
WeWeiss,
c'c'est pas démentiel moins de
mamaladies qu'on les a pas
didiagnostiqués.
- - on a un déficit de diagnostc
enen absolu et il est clair que
l'l'incidence du cancer n'a pas
chchangé dans la population du
QuQuébec depuis 2019 donc il y a
dedes gens la maison avec le
cacancer et qui ont pas été
didiagnostiqué c'est pour cela
ququ'on a besoin d'aide pour
lilibérer la capacité des hôpipx
etet reprendre le service au
mamaximum.
- - donc le message il faut sorr
leles gens dise.
MoMonsieur Carrier